hello everyone and welcome to the
semifinals of the feeder Grand Prix it's
yummy pony versus maxime beaugeois Grove
and both of them are fighting it to
reach the candidates tournament in 2020
so it's definitely a lot is at stake
here and this is the first game of the
of the classics and the Nippo has the
white pieces we do have a nice photo or
two of this matchup there you have it
Napo even bosses had had a little bit as
sign of respect towards a meal and we
all having a nice smile and there you
can see that
MVL has two bottles of water whereas nip
only has one which could mean that
Knepper prepared something vicious with
the white pieces and he doesn't expect
this to be a very long game or on the
other hand it could mean absolutely
nothing and also we have the first moves
on the board here there you have an app
opens with the d4 and the magazine
replies with Knight to f6
as you know if you play e4 against
Maxine Maxine he will 99 percent of the
time to go for his night off and if you
play d4 he will try to go for his a
groom fall defense so it this is also
the case here
d4 by Nick 1 Knight to f6 by Maxine c4
we have g6 Knight to c3 and d5 the groom
field is on the board we have Knight to
f3 and Bishop to g7 so not the the main
see captures Knight captures with Queen
to b3 and now C captures a d captures in
c4 with Queen captures and now now mvl
castles with E 4 by neppo and Knight to
c6 Bishop to e3 and now going after the
lights the darks were better with Knight
to g4 so you can't really move it like
you can in some lines of the Sicilian to
go for this some maneuver like this
because you're the d4 pawn is under
attack three times so you have to allow
the trade with E 5 by neppo and the
mountain Knight captures on e3 but this
is what he prepared F captures on d3 so
maxeen gets the bishop pair but neppo
has his preparation so Bishop to g4 and
this is a new move
a5 a5 and Knights the a5 are known moves
in the
position but Bishop to g4 is a new move
so it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game on our hands never
replies with h3 with Bishop Tadros on f3
g captors on f3 now gaining this massive
Center although the ponds in the pond
setup has been somewhat compromised but
he will use it to attack the black king
with perhaps
f4 f5 in the future or a h4 h5 with east
sucks and now h4 right away we have
Knight to e7 by MBL f5 is seems like a
very nice square for the knight
we have f4 and now comes b5 you could go
for Knight to f5 right away put pressure
on the e3 pawn wife would play some like
roguish 3 defend and then I figure out
where to go from there
but MVL says your king is still in the
center of the board it's time to open
some lines and he pushes b5 so what do
you do here if Queen captures rook b8
gets a lot of activity you don't want to
give black ideas like that especially
not a player like mvl so here Queen to
c5 never ignores it and now Knight to f5
putting pressure on the e3 pawn and now
not rook the h3 but instead of King to
f2 the king would be much safer there
than in the center of the board
but now Maxime says your king is not 1
f2 occupies the same file as my rook
let's open up the F file with f6 we have
looked at d1 now if you captured in the
pawn can capture here and that's why b4
trying to dislodge a knight so you can
capture here because the knight guards
the rook on d1 so we have Queen captures
on b4 of course you cannot move the
knight and now rook to b8 Maxine grab
some activity for his rook Queen to a3
guarding the b2 pawn and now
c5 is a very interesting move but it's a
move not not a lot of people would make
because you allow this capture screed
past C point for white you open up the
default for the rook
but then you can go Queen to c8 and then
put pressure on the C pawn and undermine
it later because it's it's actually the
white king who doesn't want the lines to
open not the black ink
but okay we have F captures on e5 now I
just grabbing that pawn D captures
opening up the default and Queen to d8
now we have Bishop to g2 by white and
here Maxime goes for Bishop captures on
e5 now he wants to open up the F file
and then create some nasty discoveries
with his Knight we have F captures on e5
and now Knight captures on h4 opening up
a discovery here King to g1 and now
Knight captures and g2 and now the idea
Maxime had was if if you captured the
night with King capture Sanji - you have
Queen to c6 with check and now after you
block you have Queen to b6 putting
pressure on the f2 square here and now
it's a very hard to decide what to play
here rook h3 is the best move here you
have to allow Queen to f2 if you want to
look for activity or or at least some
advantage with white because if you try
something like rook to f1 to prevent the
Queen from reaching after this way then
Queen III and well with the route
controlling the F file and which the
Queen being able to reach g5 and h6
black has at least a row here and then
there are no problems here for black so
nip of course did not capture the knight
first he played night Stewie for now the
knight can reach the f6 square and this
knight cannot escape anywhere you can go
here you can go here if you capture the
Queen just capture that you haven't
really achieved anything there the night
is still coming to f6 this rook can then
go to h7 did then the rook can also come
here as the knife from f6 will be
guarding all those squares but worst of
all it comes with with a fork so
probably you will have to give up the
rope here
so after 94 we have looked at b8 by
maxime and now rook the c1 preparing to
capture here then you have complete
control of the of the seventh rank and
here it's very hard to decide how to
parry the threat of Knight to f6 there
is a way it's nice it's rook to d5 this
allows black hold on you know to a
thread because after Knight f6 check you
capture pawn captures and now rook to g5
you save the night and you threaten some
very nasty discoveries and it's not
going to be
easy for for whites to get out of to get
out of it white is of course much better
here but this was the way to go
however we broke the b5 by Maxine and
now comes a move that well feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for nepo in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on exploiting the
weakness of the seventh rank and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to e7
now that the Queen left the defense of
the seventh rank now you're just
threatening Queen to h7 mate
so of course rook to d7 not allowing it
and now although you could capture on e6
it is possible nipple goes for Knight to
f6 with check with rook captures on f6
and now Queen captures on f6 and here
well you could go for Knight captures on
e3 but then it's just again Queen
captures and he's extracting f8 and rook
the h3 attacking the knight also now you
can just go troop to f3 it's gonna be
it's not gonna be possible for black to
defend so we have rooked
f7 by a Maxine but now comes Luke the
Queen to d8 with check rook the f8 and
now Queen captures on c7 it's very
important to eliminate the c7 phone it's
not just grabbing upon and it it works
wonders for white that he can grab the
pond while also threatening checkmate so
black black doesn't have a moment to
catch his breath rook the f7 now Queen
d8 check rook to f8 and now Queen to e7
again threatening mate and also with a
very interesting trick because now if
rook to f7 now you have rook to CH check
King g7 and now of course you will see
the first mate in two most likely even
without pausing the video as the poem
covers the f6 square so just Queen
captures so I know you all saw it
the King captures in real characters on
h7 that's why I didn't ask you to pause
the video it's not mate as the rook the
rooks control the 8th and 7th rank and
the pawn prevents the King from reaching
f6 so that's the little trick and nipple
had in mind so it's not possible to to
go rook f7 here
we have h 5 by Maxine but now Queen
captures on e6 with check King g7 and
now rook the c7 with check King 2h 6 and
now again feel free to pause the video
and continue the attack with white while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
again congratulations for finding such a
beautiful rook sacrifice and for those
who just want to enjoy the show its rook
captures on h5 and it's very interesting
how long this Knight remains here on G 2
because there just isn't a good time for
whites to capture it there's always a
better move
so here with King captures on H 5 and
now Quinta H 3 with check and it was in
this position I'll move 36 that Maxie
Marshall Agra resigned the game and
tomorrow he will have to win on demand
he will have the white pieces but still
but then again it's against Nepal Nepal
always plays a really crazy game so
anything had happened nobody here he
resigns because whatever you do it's
just over if you block with the knight
doesn't really help you rook h7 check
then you move in g5 Queen captures with
chair king f5 and now you can either
create some sort of a meeting meeting
threat or you can just go Queen a for
checking his ex and just pick up the
rook and just win the game because you
are up a whole rook and also if after
Queen h3 checked you don't block with
the night if you just start marching the
king king g5 still just captures king
will have to move if King get further
than just rook will well obviously the
white rook will deliver mate and if you
go start marching up the working at five
then again Queen f3 check goes here or
captures and then you just pick up the
rook and win the game because you are
now again up a whole rook so after
coming to h3 he resigned and we we do
even have a photo of the resignation
there we have it a nice handshake you
can see that nipple again respectful
he's very sorry about Maxine I'm sure he
would very much enjoy for both of them
to be in the candidates but of course
you know he will do whatever he can that
that he goes to the candidates
tournament
but yeah tomorrow one more classical
game for Maxime and a chance for him to
prove that he deserves to be in the
candidates he deserves to be in the
candidates it always eludes him for like
like a small fraction of a point and
it's just insane that that it keeps
happening to him but I don't know I
really hope that he gets it and then a
nipple can get the wild card he's
Russian he he probably would get the
wild card I know hurricane hurricane
already played in the candidates a few
times he played in the World
Championship match so maybe nipple would
get the the wild-card this time but
we'll see you know you can never predict
such things so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Volker Legrand Tom Petri Daniel
Silverberg Tobin Olson and Nicholas the
rocker now for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video syran thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day